on a day when the stakes couldn't be
higher getting the right price is
everything
it may be 300 kilometers from downing
street but britain's political future is
being watched closely here
i'm hoping for honesty and integrity
and i'm hoping that they're going to
lead us out of these
quite frankly very worrying times
well we didn't want change anyway uh the
media were focused on getting rid of
boris and they got what they wanted and
here we are
grimsby has seen its fortunes ebb and
flow back in the 60s it was the biggest
fishing port in the world
now it's at the center of seafood
processing and the offshore wind
industry but poverty levels remain high
in some parts of the town
at the last general election boris
johnson led the conservatives to power
and that win saw the party take
territory which had been held by labour
like this one for decades
nearly three years on this is the
reality for some people queuing for
essentials at just one of grimsby's food
banks right now westminster feels a long
way from here
i think we do need a little bit more
government support in
keeping the
economy
uh to a level where people can afford to
buy their own food this was only a food
bank is only meant to give temporary
aid
to individuals but what's happening is
we're getting more and more individuals
that come in on a week in week out basis
liz trusts has promised to lift the
economy and tackle the energy crisis
she'll also need to build trust in
people who are the backbone of british
business
i wouldn't vote for her just for the
fact that i kind of gave up on the
politics i think
the game's rigged and i don't think that
any of the parties
can get a handle on what's going on at
the moment it's been such a tumultuous
time that i don't think anybody has the
answers
finding those answers won't be easy as
the uk battles record inflation and the
worst energy crisis in decades emma
haywood al jazeera in northern england